pfizer has applied for emergency use of
its vaccine as the number of coronavirus
cases in the u.s rises
christina coleman is live in los angeles
with the latest developments hi
christina
hi alicia well right now covid cases are
surging from coast to coast
hospitalizations
are on the rise and officials are
putting more restrictions in place to
try and stop
the spread of this virus more than 254
thousand people have died from covid in
the u.s
and hospitalizations hit an all-time
high on thursday
with more than 80 thousand people being
treated for the virus as of yesterday
at least 30 states saw a 20 percent or
more increase in covit hospitalizations
over the past seven days 25 states also
reported a more than 20 percent increase
in covet infections
over the past week there's been a
dramatic spike in cases in the midwest
the cdc is urging people not to travel
for thanksgiving as more cities
in place here in california an overnight
curfew goes into effect
tonight the governor says non-essential
workers
or non-essential work and gatherings
must stop from 10 pm to 5 a.m in
hard-hit areas
this will impact most of the state as of
now the curfew is set to last
a month the good news a vaccine appears
to be right around the corner yesterday
pfizer
asked u.s regulators for emergency use
of its coven 19 vaccine
if approved the two-shot vaccine could
be available
as early as next month for health care
workers and people in high-risk groups
fives reported that its vaccine appears
to be 95 percent
effective now it's unclear how long it
will take the fda to
review this vaccine but considering how
fast this deadly virus
is spreading the agency is expected to
move quickly
alicia thank you christina coleman in
los angeles